foreign
[Music]
very explosive hearing on Capitol Hill
today Democratic presidential candidate
RFK Jr testified about government
censorship and surprise surprise the
Democrats on the committee tried to
censor him can't make it up take a look
how things went down I was the first
person censored by the as the chairman
pointed out on the Biden Administration
two days after he came into office this
is a letter and many of you signed many
of my fellow Democrats I've spent my
life in this party I've devoted my life
to the values of this party
there's 102 people sign this
itself
is evidence of the problem that this
hearing was convened to address this is
an attempt to censor a censorship
hearing I move that we would move into
executive session because Mr Kennedy has
repeatedly made Despicable anti-semitic
and anti-asian comments as recently as
last week to say that that I I wrote a I
created a film that encourages blacks
not to get adequate Medical Care is just
completely of orange
it's the witness's time do not censor
the witness I'm not censoring the
witness I'm not censoring the winds
it's my time and I've given it to the
witness do not censor him I'm not
censoring him if the views that you and
others
lied to me I've attributed to me if they
if that's true I can see why I shouldn't
be able to testify here today those are
not true these are defamations and
malignancies that are used to censor me
to prevent people from listening to the
actual things that I'm saying wow as a
reminder we have an exclusive town hall
with RFK Jr next Tuesday night right
here in New York City tickets are free
just go to hannity.com here with
reaction he is the chairman of the very
important house subcommittee on the
weaponization of government and the
house Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan is
with us Congressman great to have you
thank you
all right it's a hearing on censorship
and Democrats tried to censor their
fellow Democrat can you explain that
Congressman right can't make that up
nothing's new Sean they've been up yeah
they've been after this guy since as he
said and I said an opening statement
since the second day of dividing
Administration there's a tweet or excuse
me an email that goes to Twitter from
the White House that says take down this
tweet ASAP and the Tweet is from Robert
F Kennedy and there's nothing in that
tweet that is wrong everything is
factually accurate and yet they're
trying the fact the subject line of the
email says RFK misinformation but it
wasn't misinformation it was accurate
and frankly even if it was the first
amendment protects that as well so the
Democrat Party has now become the party
of censorship the party that doesn't
embrace the most important Liberty we
have our right to talk our right to
speak and to speak in a political
fashion and not be harassed and targeted
for doing so but they did it too of all
people the most famous name and Democrat
politics for the last what three
quarters of a century is the Kennedy
name and they're so committed to this
censorship they're even going after him
okay now one of the worst examples of
real censorship the FBI and this goes to
the heart of the Judiciary Committee
investigation that you are a part of the
FBI has Hunter Biden's very real laptop
and they have it in December 2019
and they authenticated it that it was
his in March of 2020 and then in the
months leading up to the election in
2020 the presidential election the FBI
was meeting weekly with big tech
companies we learned from the July 4th
ruling in that case in Missouri Eric
Schmidt was the AGS now a senator from
Missouri we learned that the Integrity
site had at Twitter guy by the name of
Joel Roth that he was being told by FBI
officials that had the laptop that
verified the authenticity of the laptop
that in fact their company and every
other big big tech company was being
told that they may be victims of
misinformation that may be about Joe and
Hunter Biden the FBI also knew that the
president's attorney president Trump's
attorney had a copy of Hunter's laptop
and that would likely be leaked lo and
behold the laptop story comes out in the
New York Post and they all censored it
and the American people didn't get to
see it and a lot of polls show it would
have had a dramatic drastic impact on
that election
yeah and Sean what we learned this week
is that day that that that story comes
out Emma Joe Morris who testified today
was the author of that story in the New
York Post the day that story comes out
the FBI just happens to be meeting with
Twitter that same day and in that
meeting someone from Twitter we got this
from Laura dimlo head of the foreign
influence Task Force at the FBI when we
deposed her three days ago that same day
Twitter's meeting with the FBI someone
from Twitter asked the FBI is the laptop
real the FBI some agent answers yes it
is and then quickly an FBI lawyer jumps
into conversation and says no further
comment so they confirmed it and then
they went to no comment later that same
day the FBI is also meeting with
Facebook Facebook asks the same question
because that day that was the biggest
story and people were wondering and
these companies were wondering because
as you pointed out Sean they've been
prepped to understand the hack and leak
operation was coming it was going to
involve Hunter Biden here it comes and
they want to know if it's real the FBI
in the meeting with Facebook Facebook
says no no comment so they will not
confirm what they know to be true in
fact what One agent kind of slipped up
it looks like and confirmed to Twitter
earlier that same day important
information now we know that they knew
the same people who were briefing about
this hack and leak thing coming they
knew ahead of time and wouldn't confirm
it and allowed the country in just days
before the most important election we
have allowed the country to to have that
story censored which is exactly what
happened let me go to this other issue
and what we now know as it relates to
Joe Biden the president and that is this
FBI informant now we have now we know
what the doj and the FBI didn't want to
hand over that 1023 form now we know
it's in that 1023 credible Source uh
human Source telling the FBI that in
fact that in the case of of Biden and
barisma that Hunter Biden who they
thought was dumb was being paid money
because Joe Biden was going to help
protect them Joe Biden Brown brags about
protecting uh barisma by demanding the
investigator the prosecutor gets fired
he gets fired Hunter continues to get
paid and the Biden family makes a
fortune in the process uh what do you
call that in Ohio uh Congressman because
I have a word for it here in New York
yeah yeah we call it wrong and we
certainly call it suspicious and I
thought what Johnson said the right word
segment Sean
yeah well you can say well you can say
it so you say it in a nice way that's
called a Shakedown uh that is called
influence pedaling
yeah but I do think what John Solomon
said earlier Sean where remember in 2019
this is what they went after president
Trump on it was all about barisma in the
phone call in Ukraine this is so when
John Solomon said we got to go back I
lived that I was in the bunker in the
basement with with Adam Schiff doing
these deposition defending president
Trump because it was so ridiculous but
they attacked president Trump on the
very thing they were involved in so
typical of the Democrats it seems to me
so John Solomon's right let's go back
and dig into those facts I think that
will be interesting something I'm going
to be doing over the next few weeks all
right Jim Jordan keep up the great work
important stuff that you guys are doing
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else